[Music]
if you have some free time on your hands
and you don't know what to do with it we
have a cure for your boredom
these DIY crafts and projects will keep
you and your friends entertained for
hours if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up
today we'll be sharing 10 pointless
projects guaranteed to waste your
precious time
chocolate playdough this no-bake
chocolate play-doh is not only fun but
it's edible too just mix together 2 cups
of flour 1/2 cup of table salt 1/2 cup
of cocoa one and a half cups of boiling
water three tablespoons of vegetable oil
and a half a teaspoon of vanilla in a
large bowl mix well until a ball starts
to form let the ball sit for a few
minutes and then knead it until it
becomes nice and soft the time will fly
by as you play and eat your new edible
project monster slime are you ready to
make some gooey slime that you can play
with all day long to make this sticky
monster slime just plays half a cup of
clear glue into a mixing bowl then add a
bit of food coloring
we like to color green because it
reminds us of big scary monsters then
add just a bit of liquid starch until
the mixture turns into slime now it's
ready to be stretched blocked and rolled
into a sticky ball for hours on end
phloem when you mix slime and foam
together it creates phloem it is a
string G and sticky paste that's so much
fun to play with to create this blob of
foam or 1/2 cup of glue into a bowl then
add your choice of food coloring and
stir next you're going to pour in 1/2
cup of liquid starch mix the ingredients
together well and squish the mixture
with your hands when the mixture becomes
a blob rinse it under running water for
a few seconds pour in some little
styrofoam balls and mix them into the
blob using your hands and there you have
it your phloem is complete marbles slime
this updated version of homemade slime
includes various colors to give it a
marbled effect all you have to do is mix
together 1/3 cup of warm water 1/2 cup
of glue and
add a bit of kool-aid or food coloring
of your choice stir it all together and
set it aside
then mix together a 3/4 cup of warm
water and 2 teaspoons of borax stir it
combine it with the first mixture and
work with your hands for 2 to 3 minutes
repeat these steps using different
colors of food coloring and then combine
the various colors have slimed together
to create marbled slime dough make quick
send get prepared to sink down deep into
your very own batch of homemade
quicksand to get started you'll need a
cup of corn starch 3/4 cups of water a
plastic bowl or bin and if you like you
can also use some food coloring make the
ingredients together for about 10
minutes until the consistency is just
right then go ahead and have some fun
sinking your hands and feet into this
fun DIY project suds eruption here's a
fun project you can do when you're
feeling a little bored it's called a
suds eruption all you need is a quarter
cup of clear hand soap 3/4 cups of warm
water 2 tablespoons of citric acid and
some food colorings mixing these
ingredients together will cause the suds
to become bigger and bigger until
they're overflowing all over the place
just make sure you have a set of towels
nearby for an easy cleanup
bubblegum the slime this slime looks
feels and smells just like real
bubblegum and we promise you won't be
able to stop playing with it as soon as
you get your hands on it just mix three
ounces of liquid starch with 8 ounces of
glue then add a bit of pink food
coloring to the mix and you have your
very own bubblegum slime place a straw
in the mixture and blow slowly to make
big and fun slime bubbles silky soft
goop this silky and smooth goop can be
made in any color your heart desires
just add a half a cup of cornstarch to
two ounces of liquid starch keep mixing
until it becomes smooth and soft and now
you're ready to enjoy running your
fingers through this super soft and
silky goop Orbeez slime how cool does
this look it's called Orbeez slime and
it's so addicting and fun to play with
just mix two bottles of glue and two
cups of water into a bowl then take a
separate Bowl and mix one teaspoon of
borax with one and a quarter cups of
water stir until the borax has dissolved
then slowly mix the borax water with the
glue mixture
add in as many Orbeez as you like and a
bit more for racks until your slime
feels just right we just love the way it
looks when it's all done we could stare
at it and play with it for hours
princess snot when a princess blows her
nose what color is our snot glittery
pink of course this is a fun project for
people of all ages just take a half cup
of hot water and add two and a half
tablespoons of unflavored gelatin and a
quarter cup of corn syrup but don't
forget to have the pink food coloring
then add glitter flakes to the mixture
and you're all done which of these
pointless projects will you be trying in
your free time let us know in the
comment section down below and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up
[Music]